Oh what is going on my little jell-o
pudding pops
that's a coffee reference if you this
man right here that's my triple fm
guess we took a quick hiatus for about a
week or so because as you can see we
revamped the channel lights camera
action
this has scared a lot of women away from
me mm-hmm
tell mama what's your name now I want a
quick update my friends with of you who
do not follow me on Twitter and
Instagram you [ __ ] should but if you
did I throw out my back so yeah how did
I hurt my back you ask it happened when
I was doing squats
I've been upping the weights but you
know I did everything right but
sometimes [ __ ] happens and you just get
hurt you know you can't prevent it from
happening you just gotta deal with it
roll the punches so in the past we can
happen so what have I been doing I
haven't been moving a lot been laying in
bed and capacitated watching TV and a
lot of celebrity sex tapes here the
whole porn and sex tape [ __ ] thing I'm
kidding by the way I don't like to watch
this [ __ ] makes me feel insecure about
my you know my shame Khan doodle now I
remember when I first watched porn and
the dudes about to do the girl and he
whips out his like King Kong ding dong
was that the only one thinking about a
look like that it's muscles look at the
third arm but anyways my guide head was
someone ok I did slip up here and there
but in terms of physical activity I had
to make a lot of adjustments for example
instead of doing heavy weights on the
squats with a lot of lower repetition I
just did body squats than I did about a
hundred to 150 of them and trust me that
[ __ ] was well it was [ __ ] tiring
especially when you got these two fun
beds right even say but to get back to
the point of what I want to talk to you
guys about and I was laying in bed I
decided to go ahead and filter through a
lot of your comments that you guys have
been leaving on the ffs videos and
though this is just my opinion from what
I've read from those comments there are
a lot of you out there that have a very
negative outlook about your health and
what I mean by that is that a lot of you
will sit there and pick out every single
quality that you hate about yourself and
use that as motivation and personally I
don't think that's healthy you see there
is a huge difference and wanted to
change to better yourself versus hitting
yourself because the goal is the same
but the end result just might be
different you see I have met a lot of
people out there
no matter how far they have progressed
physically every time they look in the
mirror they hate what they see now I
know that triple death has always been
about a healthier lifestyle especially
how you progress physically but your
mental health is just as important you
know as you change your diet and you
physically feel better about yourself
if mentally you still feel like crap
that was the whole point of this you
know for me to be completely honest with
you I never started bunny fat fit
because I look in the mirror and said
you know what David you [ __ ] butt
ugly [ __ ] you nobody gonna love you and
you know why that never bothered me
because the world may not think that I'm
so cute
but in this [ __ ] crazy ass mind of
mine I'm cute as [ __ ] look at this oh my
god my lower back I just worked my back
into a low space see where were you
restack up on that booty though right ha
but on a serious note I want you guys to
listen to this because if you invest all
your emotions into your physical
appearance is going to fail you because
physically you will constantly change
that's life
[ __ ] happens as you get older you're
gonna get these wrinkles on your face
yeah Kenny start to stand your ball sex
is flapping about smacking small little
children in the face
I hope not wear underwear you are
fighting an uphill battle time and
gravity will always win they are just
gonna pummel the [ __ ] out of your ball
sack and your face so don't get stuck on
what you don't have physically and what
you want from this workout because all
that [ __ ] even if you do get it will
eventually fade and let me ask you
something
where will that leave you you know from
this video if I want you guys to take
one thing away from this is that you
shouldn't change because you hate
yourself you should change because you
know that you deserve better but Fitness
fam it's great to be back and remember
life is always what you make it but it's
up to you to take what you deserve
let's go for broke Oh what is going on I
keep on forgetting to do these end
videos that's why you haven't seen them
in the last couple vids but remember if
you do want to get that go for broke
apparel our winner floor season is about
to end in about a month or so then we
have our new spring line coming out so
if you want to get those floral designs
make sure you go to go for broke apparel
calm but once again if you guys want to
know where I go workout
get my motivation and inspiration it's
from barbell brigade out in Monterey
Park go check them out check out their
gear and I love them very much all
because they helped me change my body
and I did but as always funny fit fit
will be back on next Wednesday and of
course you will get your Sunday upload
on time because now the channels revamp
and look all cool like a ninja what the
but anyways family make sure you guys
caught me go for broke apparel gear one
more time and of course check it out I'm
flexible
look at this right here I can do it I
can do it I threw out my back and if you
do have an eye hey how did I hurt you
how did I hurt it hot hot about her
today and what I mean by that is why
don't you focus and say something right
for a goddamn second I will whoop your
reflection here we go
nitpick along Hanukkah lambda and a lot
of you seem to you see I have seen and
met a lot of people out there no ha ha
ha but no matter how much weight they
lose our how much they proquest
pug West pull wet know how if they put
wet